you will never be able to escape from
your heart so it's better to listen what
it has to say
[Music]
every blessing ignored becomes a curse
[Music]
everyone seems to have a clear idea of
how other people should live their lives
but none about his or her own
love never keeps a man from pursuing his
destiny
[Music]
never stop dreaming
when i had nothing to lose i had
everything
when i stopped being who i am i found
myself
nothing in the world is ever completely
wrong
even a stuffed cloak is right twice a
day
the simple things are also the most
extraordinary things
and only the wise can see them
all you have to do is pay attention
listen always arrive when you are ready
[Music]
when we strive to become better than we
are everything around us become better
too
never explain your friends won't need it
and haters will continue to hate because
they also hate themselves
[Music]
when you repeat a mistake it's not a
mistake anymore it's a decision
when someone leaves it's because someone
else is about to arrive
whatever you decide to do make sure it
makes you happy
be brave take risks nothing can
substitute experience
i can choose either to be a victim of
the world or an adventure in search of
treasure it's all a question of how i
view my life
the secret of life is to fall seven
times and to get up eight times
you are what you believe yourself to be
happiness is something that multiplies
when it is divided
don't waste your time with explanations
people only hear what they want to hear
the more in the storm the quicker it
passes
now that she had nothing to lose she was
free
none of us knows what might happen even
the next minute yet still we go over
because we trust because we have faith
[Music]
fortunate as those who take the first
steps
the act of discovering who we are will
force us to accept that we can go
further than we think
if you are brave enough to say goodbye
life will reward you with a new hello
if you think adventure is dangerous try
routine this letter
live truly and forgive quickly
[Music]
life is too short or too long for me to
allow myself the luxury of living with
this so badly
life has a way of tasting a person real
either by having nothing happen at all
or by having everything happen at once
[Music]
certain things in life simply have to be
experienced
and never explained
life is such a thing
when you're enthusiastic about what you
do you feel this is positive energy it's
very simple
[Music]
stay mad but behave like normal people
have the risk of being different
but learn to do so without attracting
attention
if you start by promising what you don't
even have yet
you will lose your desire to work
towards getting it
[Music]
life always waits for some crisis to
occur before revealing itself
and it's most really
intuition is really a sudden immersion
of the soul into the universal current
of life
a life without cause is a life without
effect
if you want to be successful you must
respect one rule
never lie to yourself
[Music]
don't give in to your fears if you do
you won't be able to talk to your heart
[Music]
if i am really part of your dream you
will come back one day
miracles only happen if you believe in
miracles
keeping patient at bay or surrendering
blindly tree
bishops is through entities is the least
destructive
i don't know
remember your dreams and fight for them
you must know what you want from life
people are capable at any time in their
lives of doing what they dream of
you draw not by failing into a river but
by staying submerged in it
tears are words that need to be written
[Music]
why is patience so important because it
makes us pay attention to
people never learn anything by being
dull
they have to find out for themselves
one day you will wake up and there won't
be any more time to do the things you've
always wanted
do it now
the strongest love is the life that can
demonstrate its fragility
anyone who laughs is the expectation of
being in love in return is wasting their
time
i've learned that waiting is the most
difficult beat and i want to get used to
the feeling norm that you are with me
even when you are not by my side
don't allow your mind to tell your heart
what to do the mind give up easily
you